hi my name is david lau and i finished
simply learns cloud computing program
that was provided by caltech in
collaboration with simply learn i have
10 years experience in the technology
industry i'm currently working as a
senior business analyst and scrum master
in municipal government
and my current role demands the
understanding of office 365 azure and
other cloud technologies i chose an
upskill mainly because a lot of things
are moving to the cloud these days
as a senior business analyst and scrum
master you do have to have the latest
technologies in cloud computing
in terms of why it shows simply learn
what appealed to me most was the
flexibility in learning
on the job learning outside jobs during
my schedule to be able to learn and
obtain a postgraduate cloud computing
certification my experience with the
instructors was great they had all the
questions covered from the start to
finish the class they followed
frequently asked question model and a
question bank to make sure that all
questions are followed up the skills
acquired from this certification helped
my career
what it does is actually
it allows the exposure constantly to
cloud technology but also have that
collaboration or continue collaboration
with your technical teams this is my
long-term career goal after thinking
about it and after completing this
graduate program i think it's very
likely i will transition to a cloud or
solution architect in the next six to 12
months
as a professional who has 10 years
experience how i manage my time is
budget certain hours to during
weeknights
generally you have to be very
self-motivated and i dedicate a portion
of my fridays on saturday mornings to
learning cloud technologies on a weekly
basis
just about what my hobbies are i have a
certified scuba diver and love travel
today there are a lot of opportunities
in post-covet in terms of cloud
technologies and what i'm already
finding is that this program will allow
you to change your career or enhance
your career
with regards to cloud computing
and what i found was that learning has
to be a very proactive approach it's
something that has to be
continued and challenged on your own